Hey what's up guys, its a new day, new experiment,
and this project has extreme danger written all over it.
Now here's the basic idea,
we've seen in previous videos that we can take Coke bottles,
and fill them up with liquid propane and liquid butane,
cap them off and they would eventually pressurize,
but they wouldn't explode.
That's probably because the outside air temperature,
isn't enough to get the gas hot enough
to over-pressure the bottle.
So for this experiment today,
I thought it might be fun to use my blowtorch,
to help heat things up a little.
Here's the basic idea of the experiment:
We're gonna take two five hundred
millimeter (500mL) Coke bottles,
and empty them out.
We'll fill one of them up with liquid propane,
and the other one with liquid butane,
we'll cap them off and let them warm up to temperature.
After they have settled down and we
have had a chance to observe the differences,
we'll take a propane torch,
and gently set these bottles into the heat.
What's gonna happen? Well, they're probably gonna explode.
But, the question is, when, and how dramatically?
Finding that out is the purpose of this video today!
Now, we know that when it comes to liquid butane and liquid propane,
pressurated Coke bottles hold up no problem,
but how will a water bottle react?
These things explode at about 60 - 65 PSI,
which is about half the vapor pressure of both of those gases.
So just for fun,
I'm thinking, why don't fill these bottles,
and see if we can get them to explode on their own.
Ahhhhh refreshing
Now we fill up the bottles with propane,
we're going to use this modified tip
we made the previous video,
simply open the valve and turn it upside down,
and let it fill up the bottle.
Butane is even easier,
we just turned upside down use
something like a pair of pliers
to grab the tip and press it in.
Let's go ahead and release the valves,
and fill these bottles up.
Water bottles are not pressuring like soda bottles,
so I don't expect they'll be able to hold up,
I'm going to fill them up about halfway,
and cap them off, so let's watch what happens.
So check this out guys,
we have equal levels of propane and butane,
these are filled up exactly the same.
So if we cap them off,
which one do you think's going to explode first?
Oh!!! What the heck?!
What the heck, what the heck,
that was not expected!
The butane just popped it's top,
It looked like it was just chillin'
there no problem having fun,
not doing anything,
as the propane, I would think it was going to go off,
and all of a sudden "BOOM!" butane just in the air!
These are hold up a lot longer
than I thought they're going to,
so I think I'm just going to turn the propane,
put it closer to the flame and see if we get to explode.
oh yeah you can see it's swelling but
look at the top there, it's swelling up like a balloon
there goes wow it actually put out the
propane torch look at that it's just
hissing now it actually put out the
flame oh my goodness that was unreal
look at this bottle that is annihilated
so it's kind of interesting guys we
couldn't get the bottles to explode
right away but when i move to propane
closer to the flame you can see a balled
up like a balloon and then erupted then
went off like a gunshot and we can hear
the sound ricocheting off the mountains
behind us and this is the damage think
about this guy's all that flammable gas
and it actually put out the flame on my
blow torch
→MIND BLOWN←
so check it out guys we've left these
bottles out for about 25 minutes they've
both warmed up the outside air
temperature and holding them both in
hand the first thing I noticed is the
propane is a lot more pressurized than
the butane butane has a lower vapor
pressure apparently than propane guys I
think it is pretty hard in fact it's
making me a little bit nervous you might
be wondering about how heavy these feel
and holding them side-by-side it feels
to me like the butane might be just a
touch heavier but there is just a tiny
bit more liquid in there as well other
than that I really feel like they're
about the same way so what we're going
to do now is strike up the flame on my
propane torch and gently set these
bottles into the heat so we can observe
what happens to the liquid in a
pressurized bottle with put under
extreme temperatures let's go with
propane first moment of truth guys
pressurize bottle of propane vs
blowtorch
what happened
all right on what the heck he go to the
fire oh my goodness that was amazing so
I didn't see what happened but some
person flames went off so i thought the
bottle exploded i came to check it out
and then boom huge big fireball I didn't
even see it I was running away but I
felt the flames in my back
that was incredible torts responsive and
research with propane epic success Usain
is next I love this little rock here
works kinda like a blast shield perfect
so last time I had the bottle sitting
here and I set the propane for scheming
to this thing this time I'm gonna get
the protein towards going and sets
bottle in anything often executed a
little bit of a person especially now
that we are most oh my god hose instant
those instant I didn't have time to run
away I was just like place the bottle
and food everywhere and I didn't see if
that made a huge fireball or not because
I'm ducking and running when I can smell
the vapors here's the rest of the bottle
look at that blew it wide open now that
didn't take anything one little lick of
the flame input of the countless nut I'm
glad I got my hand out of the way in
time how much paper came off of that all
of that vaporized yeah but there was so
much pressure that actually blew the
flame out on my prepaid cards before it
had a chance at night that is
mind-blowing to me
the guys we started this experiment
today with the knowledge that we could
fill up plastic soda bottles with liquid
propane and liquid butane and at
reasonable atmospheric temperatures they
won't explode so we tried filling up
water bottles as well which were made of
a much thinner plastic and surprisingly
they held up pretty well but in the end
they did go off we notice that over time
both the propane and the butane bottles
warmed up to the point where all the
frost melted off to get things a little
bit more heated we fired up my propane
torch and stuck the bottles individually
into the propane flame as soon as the
bottle full of propane touch the flame
we saw the liquid started boiling and a
small pinhole developed which released a
little gas it didn't take much longer
though before the entire bottle exploded
in flames went everywhere now the butane
was a little bit different it looked all
calm and beautiful on the surface but it
was so highly pressurized the second we
touch it to a claim that went off the
pain the interesting thing about that
reaction is that a blew up with such
force that it blew out the flame on the
propane torch and none of the safe is
ignited I was not expecting that so in
conclusion guys yes it is possible to
store these liquid in plastic soda
bottles but it is extreme danger as the
temperature of the environment Rises the
pressure in the bottle filled and
eventually they will explode if there's
any kind of open flame in the room
sometimes they'll go up in a big
fireball sometimes the flame will go out
that's probably not a chance to really
want to take not the purpose of this
video was to do just that to play with
extremely flammable gases under pressure
with an open flame thanks for joining
for this video guys I'll be looking
for you the next one talk to you then
hey good news we got the fire out